What's up guys welcome back to another
day of metal casting experiment and you
remember in a previous project I showed
you how to make some green sand for
metal casting and I also showed you how
to make a special sandbox for metal
casting as well and the purpose of those
two videos was to create tools that we
could use to cast a metal fidget
spinner which is something I've had
hundreds and hundreds of requests for
however a channel on YouTube called
pressTube went ahead and did a first
day did a really good job and got about
seven million views in the first day so
so I don't want to redo something that's
already been done really well and I feel
like the fidgets spinner trend won't
really work on this channel I went ahead
and printed out my own templates for a
radioactive gear kind of symbol so we
could still have the same fun with sand
casting but for this video we're casting
with copper now a couple quick things I
wanted to mention when I made my green
sand I think I made it a little bit too
wet so I've been letting this sit out
for a couple of days I blend it all
together and it's a lot finer and a lot
drier but I think it's going to work
even better these copper ingots here the
ones we made in yesterday's video where
we melted down stands of copper pipes to
make four different ingots which are
worth about seven dollars and fifty
cents each apparently so the purpose of
today's video is to use our template to
create a custom styrofoam gear pack it
in green sand then remelt or copper
ingots so we can create ourselves some
kind of a random metal gear just for fun
so step number one is to cut out our
template and glue to some foam
so here we are guys I've got my
templates attached to some housing
insulation and now to trace out the
edges we're going to bring back to the
StyroSlicer
alright let's cut out the inside
alright guys our gear is finished it's
cut out of the styrofoam when it's ready
to be packed with sand now there are two
parts of our sandbox the coke and the
drag and for this I'm just going to using
the drag we're going to flip it over
turn it upside down over top of the
baseboard then we're going to take our
styrofoam gear and we're going to place
it facedown right in the center of the
board on second thought this box is a
little bit bigger than we need so I'm
going to use the smaller one instead now
if we had a really intricate mold we're
trying to copy the pattern of we would
use a sieve and take our green sand and
just sprinkle it over top like to it but
since we're using styrofoam here that's
just going to be obliterated it doesn't
really matter so much we can just grab
handfuls of our sand and pack it down
tight ramming tool
cool our stand is packed down tight so
now we can just use this scrap piece of
one by three to shimy the top and
smooth it all out
beautiful it goes on like this take out
the excess and flip it over take a look
at what we got right there is our gear
maybe we did a pretty good job guys our
gear is packed in the sand it's ready to
be cast let's take it outside our copper
has been sitting in the metal foundry
for about 20 minutes so let's open it up
and see what we got ah beautiful liquid
copper look at that
yeah alright guys where it all happened
copper looks molten that's beautiful
take that out now as I begin to pour
this it's going to start shooting flames
just to let you know nice and easy nice
and easy here we go oh cool
that's the cool
you know what's interesting about that
is as I was bringing the crucible over
to para you could see the styrofoam was
already starting to melt
just from the radiant heat and I ended
up pouring a little bit more than I
wanted to because it was cooling down a
little bit too quickly and it wasn't
filling the edges it wasn't flowing in
the way I was hoping it would but that's
okay because we can always grind this
stuff off and make a nice smooth surface
we're just going to give that a few
minutes to cool down then we're going to
quench it in some water take it out of
stand and see we got it's looking pretty
solid let's dig it out oh sweet look at
that beautiful it's very hot quenching
is in order
that's what we got oh it's not perfect
it's still pretty cool check this out
guys my OCD is killing me right now
because it didn't form a complete gear
it stopped right here where it looked
like the two sides kind of solidified
and then joined together I think that's
because the styrofoam didn't get out of
the way as fast as I thought it would I
thought it would just evaporate it
actually took quite a long time burning
off allowing the molten copper to pour
in and cool down as it did so I'm really
tempted right now just to chop this down
remelt it and cast it all over again I
think I have to do that
bangerang success that is why we made
two templates all right we're going to
have to do this best because we don't
have any time to wait we don't want to
let that copper cool down at all there
we go
flames gone out copper is liquify that's
what a pity well transfer of course
extreme is extremely hot getting up look
at it melt of styrofoam right there just
going to use the heat actually to melt
to start from right out and look how it
leaves that cavity there that's cool all
right here comes the core that's
beautiful oh I just found out I can't
call that good cumin burning I couldn't
tell if this family knew or not so I
guess we're going to find out a bit all
right let's just let that cool down for
about five minutes and see if we got any
better result fingers crossed because I
don't have to do that again it was
really incredible about that experience
was how the styrofoam just melted away
under the key to the crucible it was
actually fantastic the cavity that I
left behind in the sand was absolutely
perfect and my only concern now is as
the liquid metal went in there did it
push the sound out of place or did the
sound actually have enough integrity to
hold its position we're gonna have to
let this cool down for a few minutes
then we can dig it out and see as long
as we got a clean casting on the bottom
we can send all that stuff off the top
and still make it look pretty decent
we'll get all the wood on the side of
the box is charred from the peat of the
crucible as well
and that is some pretty intense heat and
all right well let's see we got oh that
side looks decent not perfect we got
another little imperfection right there
but looking nice alright go for the
water bath here
Hot Stuff
dang we almost got a perfect cast on
this side we got a little bit right
there and a little bit right there it
wasn't going perfectly I think that's as
good as it's going to get for today you
can definitely see the radioactive
symbol there that's cool almost looks
like some kind of genetic mutation looks
like flesh dripping off interesting
color it's heavy well there you have a
guys that's what we got it looks like
the sand actually did hold its integrity
fairly well the problem that we have is
copper cooled down so dang fast we're
getting these imperfections on the
bottom where it hits the sand and cool
it down a little bit too quickly but I
might still be able to make this work I
might take a just shop and just grind it
down and see if we can make of it so
there you have it guys that's my first
experience with hybrid styrofoam green
sand casting looks like I still need to
sharp it up on these skills a little bit
but hey it's not bad and it is a lot of
fun and we're learning as we go
but the proof of concept is here guys we
can use green sand to make pretty much
any molds that we want and cast any
metal that we want from here on out it's
just practice hey thanks for joining me
for this video today I'll be looking for
you the next one talk to you then cool
that feels really cool it might actually
make a pretty cool fidgets there as well